drink it fast or drink it slow the lips
have got to touch the tell Dawson City
Yukon Canada super North gold mining
town legend has it that captain dick
Stevenson local bartender and roustabout
was cleaning out an old miners cabin
when he found a mummified human tell
floating in a jar of alcohol he created
what is called the sour toe cocktail
which involved taking the toe and
putting it in the glass of champagne all
you have to do is go to the Dawson City
hotel bar order the sour toe cocktail
and they will watch you drink the drink
they will make sure the lips touch the
toe and then you get a certificate
thousands of people have come to join
the sour toe cocktail club there have
been some mishaps the first toe was
there for about seven years before
someone swallowed it known as on their
13th uh-huh Howard toe cocktail which
why you would keep doing it is confusing
when he got drunk enough that he tipped
backwards on his chair and accidentally
swallowed the toe donated due to an
inoperable corn that toe also swallowed
amputated due to frostbite also
swallowed anonymously sent in we don't
know why that person didn't have a tell
that toe is stolen someone just stole it
given to the bar by a local old-timer uh
in exchange for free drinks for his
nurses amputated due to diabetes sent in
anonymously with a note that said don't
wear open-toed shoes
while mowing the lawn good life was
recently swallowed in 2013 when josh
from new orleans showed up slammed the
drink toe and all put $500 on the table
the then fine for drinking a toe and
then left vanished so the bar in
response has since raised the fine to
$2,500
they also put out ads cumin toe wanted
ads luckily they didn't have to stop
serving the sour toe cocktail because
they have always kept and
croteau in the freezer click here to
subscribe or click here to watch our
other videos they've got two full feet I
just realized that like this is their on
they've done a full human set of toes
it's surprising thinking it toes so
easily really makes you think of that
big lebowski line you want a human toe I
get you to even tell apparently that's
true you barely human toes like a dime a
dozen so what do you think uh the
world's greatest hidden wonders are let
me know in the comments and I can't wait
to hear all about them